[Musique]
aux élus qu'il a fond cette loi à ceux
qui voudraient la durcir posons lui ces
questions bienvenue dans un monde un
regard bienvenu Marie dosée merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ici
donc au Sénat dans ce dôme Tournon
avocate au barreau de Paris à la tête de
votre propre cabinet spécialisé dans la
défense pénale vous êtes dans une maison
qui fait la loi ou son sens large qu'il
écrit qu'il a corrige qu'il amende qu'il
a vote s'il y avait un message à faire
passer au parlementaire quel serait-il
de laisser la loi respirer de la laisser
arriver devant les juridictions avant de
la réformer
la loi elle doit se penser mais elle
doit aussi se mettre à l'épreuve du réel
et la difficulté notamment en droit
pénal c'est que les lois se succèdent
alors même qu'elles n'ont pas le temps
d'être mis à l'épreuve par les
magistrats par la défense et que les
jurisprudences n'ont même pas le temps
de se construire qu'une nouvelle loi
vient modifier le droit applicable mais
cette surenchère législative elle ne
date pas d'hier elle a commencé il y a
déjà une quinzaine d'années et puis elle
ne cesse de se poursuivre je sais pas si
c'est aussi clair qu'un fait divers une
loi mais en tout cas oui on ressent chez
chaque député et peut-être un peu moins
au Sénat quand même mais en tout cas
chez chaque député la volonté d'exister
et de répondre à un scandale à une
émotion et parfois légitime par et bien
le le
réflexe de légiférer et ça c'est
terrible parce qu'on perd beaucoup
en sûreté on a aussi un droit à la
sûreté c'est à dire que il faut qu'on
comprenne la loi et qu'on prenne le
temps de la comprendre quelle serait la
bonne attitude du politique vis-à-vis à
la fois de la justice mais aussi de ceux
qu'on appellerait les bourreaux et les
victimes
s'agissant de la justice et surtout la
justice pénale moi j'ai une vraie
difficulté parce que elle s'est
transformée en fait divers on ne la
pense plus je vous écoute j'ai écouté
votre propos introductif mais on ne
pense plus la justice pénale on s'en
sert c'est un instrument c'est un
instrument politique c'est un instrument
qui qui aide à exciter une émotion
plutôt qu'à la calmer et à faire
semblant d'y répondre justement en
légiférant donc la seule chose que que
j'aimerais dire c'est d'abord laisser la
justice pénale tranquille un peu
elle n'est pas la réponse à tout
elle doit faire partie d'une d'un
arsenal mais il faut prendre l'entendre
prendre le temps de la mettre à
l'épreuve il faut la penser et puis il
faut agir ailleurs sociétalement dans la
prévention mais mais on ne résoudra pas
tout en légiférant et en adoptant des
systèmes ou en tout cas des lois de plus
en plus répressives parce que certains
pourraient vous dire certains élus
pourraient vous dire qu'ils ont été élus
justement pour avec comme principal
mission qui est celle de protéger les
concitoyens leurs concitoyens mais ce
n'est pas ainsi qu'on protège nos
concitoyens ce que je veux dire c'est
que depuis 1945 il n'y a jamais eu
autant de
personne n'en est tension jamais autant
de 1945 et sachez qu'avant 1945 on ne
les comptait pas donc on n'en sait rien
en réalité on arrive là à un seuil
absolument problématique et pour autant
le problème de la délinquance du rapport
à la sécurité ou du sentiment
d'insécurité n'a absolument pas évolué
dans le bon sens donc c'est pas ça c'est
pas ça
ce n'est pas en les différents de façon
outrancière qu'un législateur va
considérer qu'il remplit sa fonction et
ce pourquoi il a été élu est-ce que vous
diriez que vous faites un peu de
politique vous qu'il y a du militantisme
en vous dans le choix des affaires dans
le choix des personnes que vous
souhaitez défendre ou ne pas défendre
non parce que moi je choisis pas celles
et ceux qui me demandent de les défendre
ce sont eux ce sont elles et eux qui me
choisissent mais vous pourriez refuser
c'est assez compliqué je crois pas avoir
en 22 ans refuser de défendre quelqu'un
d'abord c'est intéressant parce que
finalement au fur et à mesure des années
les gens qui vous choisissent ne le font
pas par hasard et finalement il vous
reconnaisse donc d'abord il y a ça
ensuite je n'ai jamais refusé de
défendre quelqu'un j'ai parfois refusé
de défendre quelque chose c'est à dire
que lorsque le justicier me choisit en
me disant moi ce que je vous plaidais
c'est ça ça je veux vous plaignez ça ça
et que je ne suis pas d'accord on en
achète pas je veux rester libre et à
partir de là je dis à celui que je
défends on arrête là ou alors je me
convainc en tout cas avant j'essaye de
le convaincre que ça défense à mon
humble la vie n'est pas la bonne ou
qu'il irait mieux il serait plus plus
judicieux qu'il aille voir quelqu'un
d'autre un autre confrère qui irait dans
son sens mais moi pas donc voilà je n'ai
jamais refusé de défendre quelqu'un mais
quelque chose oui il y a des il vous
arrive de défendre des responsables
politiques est-ce qu'il y en a que vous
ne défendriez pas et je pense je sais
pas Marine Le Pen Eric Zemmour Jean-Luc
Mélenchon est-ce que vous avez des
limites
je crois que oui non je défendrai pas
Marine Le Pen hier avec Zemmour non je
l'ai défendrai pas et Jean-Luc Mélenchon
oui ah ça j'en sais rien en fait là j'ai
pas envie de de poursuivre inventaire à
la Prévert parce que il y a aussi
certaines valeurs fondamentales qui
m'appartiennent et je n'ai pas envie
d'entrer en conflit entre qui je suis et
ce que je fais voilà je crois qu'on peut
vous savez c'est un métier qui qui nous
oblige à chaque fois à douter à nouveau
à nous mettre à l'épreuve
il faut il faut sans cesse se réinventer
essayer de n'être jamais sûr de rien
c'est déjà un métier qui qui nous
empêche d'être toujours la même et qui
nous oblige à évoluer mais il y a des
fondamentaux dont je ne veux absolument
pas
m'émanciper le monde vous a surnommé
l'avocate du diable notamment parce que
l'un de vos combats c'est la défense des
enfants et des femmes de djihadistes
emprisonnés dans des camps en Syrie dans
des conditions abominables vous avez
fait condamner la France pour refus
arbitraire de rapatrier ces femmes et
ses enfants un investissement personnel
qui vous vaut des messages en pleine
nuit de ces femmes qui vous envoient des
nouvelles qui vous livrent parfois des
confidences je crois même que vous avez
demandé à votre mère d'enregistrer des
comptines que vous envoyez ensuite à ces
femmes pour qu'elles les fasse écouter à
leurs enfants êtes-vous vous toujours
sûr toujours sûr de garder la bonne
distance vis-à-vis de votre client de
vos clients d'abord je vais revenir sur
ce que vous venez de dire j'ai été
scandalisé par ce titre l'avocat du
diable pas pour moi si les gens veulent
m'appeler l'avocat du diable c'est c'est
ça parle d'eux et pas de moi et j'ai
aucune difficulté avec ça mais qu'on
rattache l'avocat du diable
à des enfants ça en dit long quand même
jusqu'à lors on n'avait jamais touché à
l'enfance l'enfance c'était l'innocence
un enfant n'était pas responsable de ce
que ses parents
fond faisait de se noms ses parents de
ce que ses parents avaient choisi jusque
là l'enfant on est touché pas qu'un
journal comme le monde titre l'avocat du
diable en ayant pour prisme de se
portrait les enfants j'ai trouvé ça
assez scandaleux voilà la page est
tournée mais encore une fois ça n'est
pas moi je m'en moque c'est par rapport
à ça et j'ai été assez outrée sur le
reste de votre question la bonne
distance oui j'en suis persuadé d'avoir
la bonne distance oui j'en suis persuadé
parce que j'ai toujours su me protéger
et parce que vous savez là s'agissant
des enfants
prisonniers depuis bientôt cinq ans plus
de 4 ans en tout cas en Syrie on n'est
pas dans le judiciaire on est plus dans
le judiciaire bien sûr que j'ai réussi à
faire condamner la France par la Cour
européenne par le Comité international
des droits de l'enfant par le Comité
contre la torture des Nations Unies mais
c'est une histoire exceptionnelle dans
la carrière d'un avocat c'est-à-dire que
moi si on m'avait dit il y a 20 ans
lorsque j'ai prêté serment vous allez
devoir vous battre pour que des enfants
enfants prisonniers en zone de guerre
derrière des barbelés soit rapatriés en
France puisqu'ils sont français mais
j'aurais éclaté de rire enfin je n'avais
pas imaginé prêté serment pour ça je
n'aurais jamais imaginé précédemment
pour ça donc non évidemment que des
liens se tissent évidemment que
lorsqu'une femme vous appelle sa tante
vient de brûler son enfant a été blessé
ou elle m'apprend la mort de la maman
d'une petite qui devient orpheline tout
ceci n'est pas codifié je ne pouvais pas
imaginer que ça allait m'arriver mais
j'ai toujours réussi à me protéger à me
protéger je n'ai jamais
considéré que mes clients étaient des
amis et que tout s'informait une grande
famille c'est aussi une façon de les
respecter que de tenir une belle
distance entre et moi je parlais de
fougue et d'engagement incroyable en
introduction vous faites régulièrement
la tournée des prisons pendant un temps
vous preniez aussi le bus avec les
familles des prisonniers pourquoi cette
immersion pour rester au plus près de
leur réalité pour mieux les comprendre
peut-être pour aller chercher justement
d'humanité en eux c'est vrai que moi
j'ai besoin d'aller beaucoup en
détention j'ai un rapport au parloir qui
est très très fort mais parce que je
suis incapable des défendre quelqu'un
que je ne connais pas ou en tout cas de
bien défendre quelqu'un que je ne
connais pas je souffre beaucoup en
comparaison médiate si je ne connais pas
celui que je défends quelqu'un désigne
il comparait devant un tribunal je le
vois 10 minutes et 20 minutes plus tard
je plaide pour lui pour moi c'est une
torture j'ai besoin j'ai besoin d'aller
plus loin qu'un dossier qu'un
procès-verbal j'ai besoin de connaître
l'histoire même si je ne l'appelais pas
et même si parfois je suis interdit par
celui-là même que je défends de plaider
ce qu'il me confie ça arrive et c'est
une torture aussi que d'avoir la clé la
clé d'une personnalité mais de ne pas
pouvoir la donner au magistrat parce que
ça fait partie du secret entre lui et
moi mais c'est ce qui me passionne ce
rapport à l'autre et cette densité au
parloir vous savez au Parlement il y a
plus rien plus de téléphone portable il
y a plus de monde extérieur il y a une
relation parfois un rapport de force
entre vous et celui que vous défendez
c'est quelques mètres ou tout se fera
casse et d'un point de vue émotionnel
c'est extrêmement fort moi j'ai besoin
d'aller en prison alors j'y vais en bus
c'est vrai mais parce que j'ai jamais
passé le permis de conduire ou plutôt
j'ai toujours échoué au permis de
conduire des affaires qui vous habitent
qui ne vous quittent pas oui il y a des
visages qui m'habitent et qui ne me
quittent pas pas des affaires lequel
visage réel oh je le visage une femme le
visage d'une femme lambda pas du tout
des c'est pas du tout des dossiers
médiatiques mais le visage d'une femme
le visage un enfant aussi jeune de cet
enfant qui
qui pleurait et qui devant le juge des
enfants
la juge lui avait demandé mais pourquoi
tu pleures et en regardant sa mère et il
avait dit parce qu'elle pleure cet
enfant était un enfant battu par sa mère
ce sont des images ce qui me hante pas
des affaires je parlais de votre fougue
de votre passion l'un de vos confrères
et amis Dominique tricot dit de vous
c'est l'une des meilleures avocats de ce
pays elle a une très grande qualité
d'écoute ce qui est rare chez les
pénalistes et dit-il claire d'oublier
une console ajoute elle est pugnace
motivée impliquée quand elle prend la
défense de quelqu'un elle va jusqu'au
bout c'est quoi jusqu'au bout mais je
pense que je suis obsessionnelle
ce qui a aussi c'est travers et et je
pense que peut-être aussi comme j'ai été
très longtemps
quand j'étais enfant ou adolescente aux
conservatoire de répéter des gammes et
de répéter des arpèges je pense que ça
répondit aussi à ce qui me ce qui me
caractérise même également c'est ce goût
de l'obsession c'est vrai que c'est vrai
que je ne peux pas lâcher je ne peux pas
lâcher je ne peux pas abandonner
pathologique je sais pas peut-être
peut-être donc je pense que ça c'est
ça convient ma profession évidemment
vous dites cette profession rend fou
elle peut rendre fou il faut faire très
attention elle peut rendre fou elle peut
rendre fou parce que d'abord c'est très
rare aujourd'hui les professions où on
se lève le matin sans savoir ce qui va
arriver garde à vue interpellation
échec drame joie bon émotionnellement on
est tout le temps malmené
donc ça c'est assez rare et puis c'est
une c'est une profession
il y a quand même une sacrée pression
c'est difficile de de se sentir
responsable et donc coupable du destin
de quelqu'un moi alors bien sûr que
c'est les magistrats qui jugent c'est
vrai mais c'est pas possible de ne pas
de ne pas culpabiliser lorsqu'on plaide
un acquittement et que 15 années de
réclusion criminelle sont prononcés
enfin c'est oui ça ça peut rendre fou
votre premier patron Michel cognitz dit
que vous allez même réussir à le
convaincre de défendre un client
gratuitement gratos dit-il ce qui nous
amène à un point intéressant que les
gens ignorent peut-être c'est comment se
paye un avocat lorsqu'il accepte
notamment une affaire qui est médiatisée
mais dont on comprend qu'il ne va pas la
faire payer est-ce que ce sont du coup
les affaires moins médiatisées comment
se paye un avocat
les honoraires sont libres donc c'est
très difficile et moi je viens d'une
famille où il y a pas de profession
libérale c'est vrai que j'avais pas du
tout cette culture là je veux dire c'est
mes parents sont fonctionnaires mes
grands-parents étaient ouvriers donc
c'est vrai que cette culture de demander
de l'argent pour moi ça a été un vrai
problème j'ai eu énormément de mal avec
ça et je l'ai beaucoup délégué
d'ailleurs je continue encore un petit
peu parce que c'est toujours quelque
chose ce sentiment de se vendre c'est
difficile pour moi j'aime pas ça
maintenant bien sûr les honoraires sont
libres ont on les fixe alors moi je une
comparaison médiate entre temps et temps
une information judiciaire entre-temps
et temps évidemment qu'une audience
criminelle demande une cour d'assis va
coûter plus cher qu'une audience devant
le tribunal correctionnelle parce que ça
prend plus de temps ça se compte déjà en
temps passé et en heure passée
évidemment il y a des mais faire que
vous acceptez de défendre gratuitement
parce que médiatique
ah non ça non ça n'a rien à voir avec ça
et d'ailleurs les quelques personnes qui
ont osé
me dire non je vous paye pas de toute
façon c'est médiatique
ça j'ai toujours répondu mais je suis
pas payée par les médias et surtout je
me suis acheté par personne vous me
demandez la lettre achetée donc ça c'est
pas ça du tout non il m'est arrivé de
défendre gratuitement des personnes
parce qu'elle me bouleversait parce
qu'elle n'avait pas d'argent parce
qu'elle ne pouvait pas accéder à l'aide
juridictionnelle et parce que je veux
garder la liberté de pouvoir le faire
vos détracteurs disent de vous que vous
êtes trop donneuse de leçons vous êtes
un peu isolé dans le monde des avocats
vous ne fréquentez pas tellement les
avocats de votre génération vous dites
que vous ne buvez pas des pots avec eux
votre conjoint l'écrivain Marvin nous
dit c'est une sauvage elle n'a aucun
code mondain elle est mal à l'aise avec
son époque et nourrit un complexe
d'illégitimité qui oblige à redoubler
d'efforts est-ce que vous êtes plus à
l'aise finalement avec les délinquants
présumés que vous défendez qu'avec le
monde des avocats qu'avec vos collègues
avocats vous êtes plus à l'aise dans ce
non mais je suis plus à l'aise
effectivement avec celles et ceux que je
défends qu'ils soient d'ailleurs
victimes ou
ou pour présumer ou auteur présumée ou
mise en cause ou mise en examen ou
prévenu ou accusés je défends les deux
attention c'est très important et je
tiens à le faire toujours je ne veux pas
moi je sais que certains confrères se
spécialisent et dit je ne défends des
victimes moi je ne défends pas que des
accusés je défends aussi
en qualité de partie civile Fabienne
Boulin je défends l'association des Amis
Ghislaine Dupont et Claude Vernon qui
sont victimes du terrorisme je défends
certains blessés certaines veuves de
l'attentat de Karachi donc je fais
attention à ça parce que j'en ai besoin
et je défends évidemment certaines
victimes de violences sexuelles donc oui
c'est vrai que je suis plus à l'aise
dans mon rapport au travail que dans
tout ce qui est périphérique mais ça a
toujours été je suis quelqu'un d'un peu
isoler peut-être j'ai jamais eu besoin
en fait vous voyez de
du rapport social du rapport aux autres
en dehors du travail mais c'est pas pour
autant que je n'écoute pas ce qu'on dit
j'ai des amis confrères et j'aime
discuter avec eux et il m'arrive
régulièrement de prendre mon téléphone
pour pour leur demander conseil mais je
suis pas très mondaine voilà c'est et je
critique pas ce qu'ils le sont et c'est
juste que oui c'est ça me rend pas très
à l'aise pour comprendre qui vous êtes
aujourd'hui en se penche un peu sur
votre parcours personnel si vous le
voulez bien vous avez grandi à Commercy
petite commune de Lorraine aujourd'hui
région Grand Est vous êtes vous l'avez
dit petite fille d'ouvriers votre mère
était institutrice en maternelle votre
père avait aussi une formation
d'instituteurs mais il s'est lancé en
politique et il est devenu maire de
Commercy puis député maire de la Meuse
et votre passion à vous c'était la
lecture vous dévoriez les livres de la
bibliothèque municipale tenue par la
mère de votre meilleure amie je crois
c'est vrai vos premières lectures furent
la Comtesse de Ségur et ça vous a
tellement plu et influencé vous êtes
devenu croyante et que vous avez demandé
à faire du catéchisme jamais les choses
à moitié non j'avais
c'est quand même vraiment le bien et le
mal
alors même que voilà 40 ans plus tard on
en est plus tout à fait là et et oui
j'adorais lire j'adorais la bibliothèque
municipale et puis avec ses escaliers
qui séparent les petits des grands et je
me souviens de la première fois où j'ai
franchi ces escaliers parce que j'avais
le droit d'accéder à la bibliothèque des
grands oui bien sûr je me souviens très
bien de ça ouais et puis la Comtesse de
Ségur que voulez-vous
elle a lueur de celle que vous êtes
aujourd'hui quel conseil donneriez-vous
à la petite fille que vous étiez que lui
diriez-vous avant qu'elle ne se lance
dans la vie
de gagner en confiance peut-être mais en
même temps
moi je pense que l'absence de confiance
elle oblige elle oblige à douter et ça
c'est très très important vraiment très
important je finalement je travaille pas
trop ce qui est censé être une faiblesse
parce que je crois vraiment que le monde
souffre d'une
trop grande confiance en Lui trop
d'assurance j'ai un document à vous
proposer Marie doser c'est une archive
qui vient des Archives nationales nos
partenaires dans cette émission il
s'agit de la loi du premier décembre
1900 autorisant les femmes à exercer la
profession d'avocate à l'initiative de
jeunes Chauvin que ce texte fut adopté
la première qui prête à serment fut
Sonia Olga ballakowski petit le 4
décembre 1900 Jeanne chauvince la
deuxième cinq jours plus tard le 9
décembre et elle fut la première femme à
plaider un peu plus d'un siècle donc que
les femmes peuvent être avocates
qu'est-ce qu'elles ont apporté à la
justice
alors
ces 10 dernières années elles ont
bouleversé la défense comment allons
bouleversé parce que moi quand j'ai
commencé il y a 20 ans
d'abord un n'était pas là je me souviens
de cours d'assise avec 5 6 7 confrères
et puis et puis moi toute seule et on
fait elles ont transformé la plaidoirie
il n'y a plus d'éloquence à papa c'était
merveilleux j'adorais j'adorais voir les
confrères avec vraiment les effets de
manche et puis ce qui vous a donné envie
de faire ce métier
pas tout à fait moi ce qui m'a donné
envie de faire ce métier c'est l'autre
défendre l'autre pas l'éloquence et
c'était éloquence là elle était vraiment
grandi au compte et pas beaucoup de
dossiers beaucoup de citations beaucoup
d'intelligence beaucoup d'humour les
magistrats posaient leurs crayon et et
et leurs feuilles puisque de toute façon
l'important c'était quand même
l'exercice oratoire on était au théâtre
voilà mais un merveilleux théâtre
intelligent et qui disent qui en disait
beaucoup sur la défense mais peu sur le
dossier et parfois assez peu sur celui
qu'on défendait nous nous sommes arrivés
il a fallu trouver autre chose il a
fallu parce qu'on n'a pas les mêmes
voies parce qu'on n'a pas le même corps
parce qu'on n'a pas le même rapport non
plus au tribunal parce que parce que on
commençait donc pas avec la mamie
assurance on a trouvé autre chose et je
pense sincèrement que les femmes et j'ai
vu les avocats de commencer les femmes
ont travaillé énormément elles ont été
plus techniques elles sont allées plus
souvent des tensions elles sont allées
plus loin dans la personnalité de celles
et celui qu'elle défend donc de
confiance en eux peut-être oui mais
parce qu'il fallait gagner un registre
et ce registre là il a été gagné et ce
que je constate aujourd'hui c'est que
finalement ce sont plutôt les confrères
qui commencent à plaider comme les
consœurs s'inspirer de vous oh oui
écoutez celui qui a 25 30 ans commence
une plaidoirie en revenant à l'éloquence
à papa je suis pas persuadé qu'il va
beaucoup intéressé les magistrats et je
pense qu'aucun qu'aucun confère ne
prendra ce risque désormais les
magistrats ce sont habitués finalement à
des piloiries beaucoup plus techniques
ce qui n'empêche pas l'émotion
ni les locaux comment ni l'éloquence ni
l'éloquence bien sûr c'est une forme
d'éloquence mais en tout cas celle là je
pense qu'elle a progressivement disparu
parce que les femmes et bien
ont inventé autre chose c'est fou quand
on sait que le mari de Simone Veil lui
avait déconseillé de se lancer dans ce
métier parce que ça n'était selon lui
pas la place d'une femme d'aller au
contact des malfrats des délinquants je
me souviens je pense que j'avais une
semaine de barreau et un confrère
m'avait m'avait ramené en deux détention
puisqu'il était en voiture et je me
souviens de cette phrase cette phrase
qui m'avait qui m'avait dit en disant
amusez-vous mais pas très longtemps le
pénal n'est pas fait pour les femmes on
se souvient très bien c'était il y a 20
ans plus j'ai des photos maintenant à
vous présenter Marie-Josée
c'est un rituel dans cette émission
voici la première évidemment vous le
reconnaissez Robert Badinter immense
avocat immense ministre celui qui a fait
abolir la peine de mort en France si
vous deviez nous parler de son plus
grand apport à la justice quel serait-il
c'est compliqué parce que on sait tous
l'immense à Port de Robert Badinter
c'est son combat c'est son combat contre
la peine de mort
mais je l'ai entendu une fois et je l'ai
rencontré à deux reprises il se dégage
de lui ce qu'il devrait se dégager de
tout avocat pénaliste il y a en lui à la
fois une colère mais aussi une émotion
une révolte et en même temps une raison
qui hypnotise tous ceux qui croient son
chemin et en cela Robert ballintter il
est avocat dans le sens le plus pur et
le plus absolu du terme
il est habité par ça il y a quelque
chose en lui qui qui est vraiment de
l'avocat pénaliste et c'est ça cette
cette façon de de ne rien concéder et
j'avoue
ça vous tenterait
oh non non ministre de la Justice
une deuxième photo il s'agit de Yannick
Morez mère démissionnaire de
Saint-Brevin-les-Pins en
Loire-Atlantique on a incendié son
véhicule et une partie de sa maison
parce qu'il était favorable à
l'ouverture d'un centre d'accueil pour
migrants quel regard la fille de mère
porte sur son cas à lui et de manière
générale le sort réservé aux élus
aujourd'hui
aux élus locaux
je pense tout ça dramatique dramatique
parce que
en plus tout ça
tout ça arrive à des élus locaux ceux
qui sont les plus proches des gens moi
mon père effectivement était maire d'une
toute petite ville un Commercy donc il
se passait pas de mettre son que les
gens viennent lui parler parfois parfois
d'ailleurs le whispy et parfois le
sourire mais et voilà c'est tellement
important l'élu et qu'on en vienne à
s'attaquer à des élus locaux enfin bon
l'actualité aujourd'hui et et effrayante
donc il y a quelque chose de cassé là en
ce moment d'auront pu de casser et
j'écoutais une conférence il y a pas
très longtemps réparer le dialogue mais
mais encore faut-il qu'il y en ait la
difficulté elle est là c'est qu'on a
vraiment le sentiment d'une fracture
entre les élus locaux et les administrer
d'une fracture vertigineuse qui
oui qui était effrayante vraiment j'ai
une dernière question Marie dosée qui
est en lien avec le lieu dans lequel
nous sommes nous sommes entourés de
quatre statues vous avez un peu repéré
avant l'émission qui représente chacune
une vertu il y a la sagesse la prudence
la justice et l'éloquence laquelle de
ces vertus vous parle le plus je pose la
question à une avocate je suis peut-être
une idée de la réponse encore que
pourriez-vous surprendre
la femme choisit la prudence l'avocat
choisi la justice et je pense que la
prudence est de mise aujourd'hui et elle
doit aussi
gagner l'institution judiciaire la
réponse était donc surprenante merci
merci Marie dosée d'avoir été avec nous
dans cette émission merci d'avoir
partagé votre regard et un peu de votre
monde avec nous et merci à vous de nous
avoir suivis comme chaque semaine à très
vite sur Public Sénat merci merci
[Musique]